please welcome Missy Teigen the official
pronunciation is tigon but she's been
going professionally as Teigen because
she just got tired of correcting people
when she was young she's opened a
Pandora's box with that bad news fine
Teigen tagging let's just call her
fierce and not just because of this
sparkly silver Zuhair Murad but also for
this Twitter clap back when a hater
asked with quote the utmost respect as
Chrissy Teigen pregnant again she fired
back I just had a baby but thank you for
being so respectful the parents hit up
the Hulu afterparty
Chrissy quit changing her dress and hair
and despite that bruise on her leg a
supermodel owned the dance floor until
about 11:00 p.m. kind of notice you have
a little ring on your finger just mean
anything it doesn't mean anything
I'm age no I mean all these I just
borrowed don't read into anything but
you said you had a happiest you've ever
been I am very much the very PDA
friendly couple held each other all
night tom barely let go until he got
camera shy the amazon after-party we're
hiding posed with TV husband Tim Gunn
Congrats man thanks so much looks really
good
Darren Criss my darling Mia you you roll
the windows down and pump the music up
in my life did you have that plan did
you think about it beforehand Morris I'm
thinking about it for a while
really and now the next thing is like a
wedding so I think you're good yep
what a year 2018 crazier the pair has
been together for eight years their love
fest at left former Glee co-star Lea
Michele and tears literally crying right
now
[Music]